bonjour je m'appelle José Cachin je suis
maire adjoint délégué à la culture et
l’avènementiel à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et si je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est pour vous donner trois bonnes
raisons d'aller assister à au concert de
trois cafés gourmands
[Musique]
la première raison elle est très simple
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer l'actualité
et vous avez certainement entendu dire
que trois catégories aller se séparer à
l'issue de la tournée 23 24 donc
j'aurais tendance à dire que pour les
inconditionnels c'est une occasion
supplémentaire de les voir et c'est
peut-être la dernière fois et pour ceux
qui sont qui ne les connaissent pas
encore et ben c'est l'occasion des
découvrir mais également peut-être aussi
de les voir la dernière fois la deuxième
raison c'est que c'est un album auquel a
collaboré Jean-Jacques Goldman
tout le monde connaît Jean-Jacques
Goldman bien évidemment et la pâte qu'il
met à chaque fois
démontre ou témoigne en tout cas que
c'est un label de qualité et puis enfin
la troisième raison elle est toute
simple c'est que trois cafés gourmands
ça s'écoute ça se chante et ça se danse
donc c'est une occasion inespérée de
passer une soirée en famille
[Musique]
voilà en quelques mots les trois bonnes
raisons d'aller voir trois cafés
gourmands alors trois cafés gourmands
c'est un concert qui se déroulera le 20
octobre à 20h30 à la ferme du Mali
elle veut juste dire je t'aime